بعد شهر واحد فقط من إطلاق Apple
لأجهزة iPhone 10s و iPhone 10s max ، حصلنا
على جهاز iPhone 10 R
أقل بحوالي مائتين وخمسين دولارًا
من نظرائه ، فإن 10r في
الواقع تشبه إلى حد بعيد
الموديلات الأعلى جودة التي لديها  نفس الشريحة ، لذا فهي
تشحن نفس السماعات اللاسلكية بنفس السرعة
كما أنها تدعم خاصية التعرف على الوجه
ولكن هناك بالفعل بعض الاختلافات الرئيسية ،
لذا دعونا نتحقق منها
أولاً ، فلنتحدث عن الشاشة التي يبلغ
حجمها 6 بوصات واحدة
مقارنة بـ 10  s التي تبلغ مساحتها خمس نقاط
ثماني بوصات ولكنها أصغر قليلاً
من شاشة iPhone 10 s
max ، كما تحتوي 10 R أيضًا على شاشة LCD
مقارنة بشاشة OLED في الطرف الأعلى
لهواتف I ، ودقة iPhone 10 ARS
أقل بقليل من 1080 بكسل لذا  لا يمكننا
حتى تشغيل مقاطع فيديو عالية الدقة وهي
بالتأكيد عيبًا
في التصميم التالي ، فإن 10 R أثقل
وأثخن قليلاً من iPhone 10 s
ولديها إطار يدور حول الشاشة
رقم ثلاثة ، الكاميرا iPh  تحتوي واحدة 10 R
على كاميرتين فقط ، واحدة في الأمام
والأخرى في الخلف ، لكن
الطرز الأعلى بها ثلاث كاميرات ، واحدة هي
عدسة مقربة أو طويلة تتيح لك
التكبير دون الإضرار
بجودة الصورة ، ثم هناك الزاوية العريضة العادية
رقم العدسة للألوان لدى Apple ستة
ألوان ممتعة جديدة للاختيار من بينها ، إنها المرة الأولى التي تقدم
فيها Apple لونًا غامقًا
منذ iPhone 5c قبل بضع سنوات
وتقول إنها أجرت الكثير من الأبحاث
لاختيار الألوان التي تعتقد أنها ستعجبك
أفضل بطارية رقم خمسة قد
تفترض أن الموديلات الأعلى
ستتمتع بعمر بطارية أفضل لكن Apple
تقول أن iPhone 10 R سوف يستمر
لفترة أطول عند استخدام الإنترنت مقارنة
بـ 10s و 10's max في
نهاية اليوم iPhone  10 R هو حقًا
للأشخاص الذين يمتلكون iPhone 8 والموديلات الأقدم
الذين يبحثون عن ترقية ، لذلك إذا
لم تشاهد الكثير من مقاطع الفيديو عالية الدقة
ولا تحتاج إلى عدسة تليفوتوغرافي رائعة
على الكاميرا ،
فأنت لا تساوم حقًا  كثيرًا
مع هذا النموذج
أنت